the scale typically used to justify a
movie success as the amount of money it
turns at the box-office and that's
understandable
if one movie earned more than another
that means more people saw it but that
definitely doesn't mean it's better
sometimes truly terrific films flop hard
as far as the bean counters are
concerned here are some of the best
box-office bombs edge of tomorrow
without a proper marketing strategy that
gets butts in seats movies can fail at
the box office which is what happened to
doug liman 2014 film edge of tomorrow
based on Hiroshi sakurazaka novel all
you need is kill the trailer looks like
just another generic sci-fi flick except
this time with a bit of Groundhog Day
mixed in what but edge of tomorrow is
actually a whole lot more than that it's
a sci-fi film that channel d-day into a
future war against an alien race with
the ability to reset the day that is
until Tom Cruise comes along and breaks
their winning streak it's basically a
video game brought to live action in the
best way possible
spawn advance die repeat despite great
reviews edge of tomorrow was a
box-office dud and make no mistake the
bulk of the film's failure hinged on
it's botched a marketing campaign the
studio basically retitled it lives die
repeat when it was released on video if
that doesn't scream bad marketing
nothing does Dredd comic-book movies are
all the rage in Hollywood these days but
that's no guarantee for success thread
from 2012 is the perfect example despite
solid reviews from critics it only grows
to thirty five point six million dollars
against the 50 million dollar budget the
film takes a few liberties with the
source material but there's no denying
it captures the attitude of the comics
pretty well it's a brutal work of art
and the movie that fans of the comics of
waited decades to see plus it features a
motorcycle chase scene that rivals the
Matrix Reloaded that's a pretty sweet
bike right too bad it wasn't sweet
enough to green-light a sequel yes
oshi asians / zodiac the mystery of the
Zodiac killer is a tale that's arguably
as intriguing and perplexing as Jack the
river which is why so many people have
tried to dramatize the story including
David Fincher who adapted Robert Cray
Smith's crime clock zodiacs for the big
screen in 2007 laying out an extensive
in-depth case like the Zodiac killer for
a general audience as difficult but
Fincher crafts a compelling retelling of
not only the murders but also the
manhunt surrounding them
I'm not Pacific couple that was a
stellar cast that included Robert Downey
jr. Mark Ruffalo and Jake Gyllenhaal and
you've got a great drama unfortunately
the film grossed just eighty four point
eight million dollars at the box office
but found new life on home video
scoring profits of around 20 million
dollars Hugo the director responsible
for hard are films like Goodfellas The
Departed and the wolf of Wall Street
isn't exactly who you'd expect to direct
a PG movie but Martin Scorsese did a
great job of the dramatic adventure
Hugo Hugo received stellar reviews from
critics but that wasn't enough to propel
the movie into box-office glory it
grossed almost a hundred and eighty six
million dollars worldwide against an
estimated production budget of 150 to
170 million dollars although it failed
to reach the box office Heights Judea
was still a brilliant film and the rare
look into the rise of automation in the
early 20th century
Scorsese blended steampunk elements into
a historical film with a Parisian
backdrop a combination seldom seen in
Hollywood drawing cues from a trip to
the moon and the impossible voyage
rather than modern superhero flicks and
that's what makes it beautiful the road
based on the novel of the same name by
Cormac McCarthy the road was released in
2009 and grossed a mere twenty seven
point six million dollars against a
twenty five million dollar production
budget first the facts of the film a
doubt at all is a miracle
anyone who's read a McCarthy novel knows
how difficult they are to translate onto
the silver screen
seriously it's just a whole lot of that
how do you show audiences of a film
they're watching is set in a
post-apocalyptic world simple make
everything dark and gray there's rarely
been a more haunting representation of a
post-apocalyptic world and that's why
this film is so important to the genre
it isn't about why the world is the way
it is instead it's about the father-son
relationship of the main characters sure
it might be bleak but it's a story well
worth seeing Master and Commander the
far side of the world based on Patrick
O'Brian's naval novel Master and
Commander was meant to be a war movie
blockbuster unfortunately for Russell
Crowe who starred in the often forgotten
film it was released the same year as
the cartoonish non war blockbuster
Pirates of the Caribbean the curse of
the Black Pearl which introduced Johnny
Depp's captain Sparrow to the world
turns out there wasn't enough room for
two adventures on the high seas Captain
Jack Sparrow but forget all that junk
Master and Commander is a feast for the
eyes depicting an often forgotten period
of European history and it doesn't so
remarkably well unlike many other
historical dramas it gets the real-life
details mostly right and Crowe brings it
all home with his exceptional
performance the facts of the film
received a whopping 10 Oscar nominations
underscores its excellence and the
legendary film critic Roger Ebert gave
the film a rare perfect score saying it
achieves the epic without losing sight
of the human speed racer
the Wachowski made a name for themselves
by writing and directing the Matrix
trilogy when it came time for them to
tackle a new project they chose to bring
the classic Speed Racer series to life
on the big screen with the Rachel skis
at the helm and the name recognition of
the property it was a shock to see speed
race a flop at the box office grossing
ninety three point nine million dollars
on a budget of a hundred and twenty
million dollars
the film's cartoonish visuals may have
turned off some critics but for
franchise fans it was exactly what the
film needed to capture the your of the
original anime what's interesting though
is that the movie includes themes of
politics and corruption as well as
general issues in society and those
themes unfold on a number of levels yet
and never forgets that it's still a kids
movie speed racer didn't fall into the
trend of gritty reimagining that plagued
the 2000s instead it takes a funny witty
and light-hearted charm that's exactly
what fans wanted it's just too bad more
people didn't see it The BFG Steven
Spielberg ranks among the greatest
living filmmakers and the fact that he's
the highest-grossing director of all
time only bolsters his legacy he's the
guy that pretty much created the summer
blockbuster after all but none of that
helps The BFG grossed more than 180 3.2
million dollars worldwide on an
estimated 140 million dollar budget in
2016 the movie was a recipe for success
it was directed by Spielberg distributed
by Disney and is based on the famed
Roald Dahl novel of the same name so why
it failed to break 200 million dollars
is a mystery monetary problems aside the
vfg is a criminally underrated film
despite its big-budget fantastical
elements and a summer release it was
still far from your traditional summer
tentpole basically it was a big-budget
fantasy without the extravaganza it's
not so much about the spectacle as it is
about the journey and that's where
audiences will find themselves
captivated by Mark Rylance is
outstanding motion capture performance
as well as the irresistible charm of
Hollywood newcomer Ruby Barnhill do
yourself a favor and check out the BFG
ASAP thanks for watching click the
looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know your love thing
[Music]